il essaye de se réchauffer comme ils le
peuvent alors que ce soir là le
thermomètre affiche trois petits degrés
les joueurs de football américain des
templiers d'elancourt utilise un
chauffage électrique en extérieur sur le
bord du terrain
forcément le froid alors malema qui
frise pour attraper de balancer un petit
peu moins facile mais certaines parties
du jeu ça se contrôle pas donc il faut
faire avec cette eau objectif éviter les
blessures au niveau des mains comme il
fait froid les ballons sont durs donc
c'est vrai qu'au niveau des doigts ça ça
limite la casse parce que l'on a vite
fait de sauter une articulation
mais par contre l'avantagé du froid
c'est que en amant mal en ce sens - le
staff est également promise à un
échauffement pendant la mi temps pour
éviter cette fois ci les pépins
musculaires
on est revenu un peu plus tôt sur le
terrain pour voir le temps de faire un
bon échauffement pour être sûr d'être
prêt repartirait remettre les gars de
dents est vrai que sur le premier drive
en attaque ils ont eu du mal à se
remettre dedans mais une fois qu'ils
sont réchauffées après deux trois coups
de casque
c'était reparti le lendemain les
températures tombent à moins de 3 degrés
en plein après midi sur le stade gilbert
chant sac de trappes pour combattre le
froid les joueurs ont élaboré des
stratégies de cycle
en dessous la crème mais vos pas
nous qui colle au corps trois morceaux
[Musique]
et tous accros changement également dans
la préparation d'avant match les joueurs
sortent au dernier moment pour
s'échauffer
pas de coupure au programme jusqu'au
début de la partie donc le clan corse
après l'effort dans une couche les
chemises à fleurs quand même utile pour
que le corps monte en température et
s'apprête à aller fort le froid des
conditions de jeu compliqué pour le
poste de gardien de but
immobile une grande partie du match
mamadou magassa doit composer avec ce
facteur
il faudrait toujours parler ça ça permet
de garder regarder vraiment l'esprit à
chaud en cas de dominos de notre part
faudrait que je rêve toujours mobile
c'est à dire à faire les petits
mouvements pour pas peut pas choper un
coup de frein le week-end prochain les
températures devraient remonter sur les
terrains dix degrés sont attendues pour
ce week end pour le plus grand bonheur
des joueurs
[Musique]